so I'm just gonna get started because I
watched all of this show over the
weekend and it was amazing I loved your
performance by the way
um I just want to ask you what did you
pull inspiration from for Diane Farah's
character how did you approach her
because she's so hard to pin down
sometimes and she's got so many
different dimensions to her character
um how did you approach that character I
think that's what I'm always looking for
in a character is
um just a lot of Dimension and
a lot of different
contradicting qualities to to play
around with
um
I've never worked in this genre before
so I was really looking forward to that
and I also wanted to work with Sean Ryan
so when we were first talking to each
other I asked Sean why he wanted to work
on this show what did it mean to him
um
because there's so many things he could
work on why this one and one of the
things he said that
um stood out to me was that he wanted to
um
sort of investigate the different
Dynamics between men and women when they
have to work together in a professional
setting and what that looks like what
the difficulties are how they get things
done
um and so it was
it was nice to get to play in this
fictional world we have a female
president on the show and
um Diane Farm my character is her chief
of staff
so I'm really looking out for her best
interest and doing everything that I can
and you know because there's so many
different uh interest groups and so many
different departments and personalities
that you have to navigate you know every
day is a different day and you know you
you
have to say and do things that may not
look good on paper and I thought that
was really interesting because that's
that's so
real and so true to life I mean I I
don't know if you can be a successful
politician
without
knowing how to bend the rules and when
um so so that was really fun for me
there wasn't any one person that I base
the character off of but
um in terms of the appearance I did
I did send Sean Ryan a photo of my
friend uh Susan Choi who's an author and
she has like this beautiful
um silver hair and I sent it to him and
I was like I would like to look like
this
I mean it's an amazing look
he was he was a little taken aback but
um thankfully Caroline our hair
department head uh was amazing and she
was able to to whip something together
for us and she was excited to
um and you know I think another thing
that I noticed was during the pandemic a
lot of women let their natural hair
color
um come out they they stopped dyeing
their hair because you know we couldn't
go to hair salons or anything like that
and so I think since the pandemic I've
noticed so many beautiful older women in
their hair and I think I wanted to pay
tribute to that somehow yeah for sure I
mean that that hairstyle was amazing
when I first saw her come out I was like
oh okay that's what we're doing here
today
um but I do want to get into some
spoilers because we are going to post
this after release
um and I do I really I'm interested in
hearing your opinion about Diane and her
um her sort of character journey I would
say I feel like when I'm watching her I
was it was hard to pin down whether or
not she was the perpetrator I feel like
I kind of was like oh okay like okay so
she's good oh no wait
um do you think that what she does is
out of self-preservation or do you think
it's because she considers you know
she's trying to protect the president
more than anything I think it's really
hard sometimes you just get backed into
a corner
you know and there's no
and you know if
hindsight is always uh you know uh 2020
and
um
it's really difficult when there are so
many different moving parts and you just
kind of have to do your best and and
hope that you're making the right
decision uh every step of the way and I
think this is just one of those times
where
Diane Farr couldn't get ahead of it you
know I think ideally she would have
liked to but there's so many uh
different players and they all have
their own interests and their own uh
moral compass you know I I don't think
that Diane Farr
uh would ever have signed up for this
for for what ended up happening
um
and and it was kind of unfortunate I
felt I felt kind of sad for her actually
because I think she really truly meant
it when she
um
said that she was doing this out of
loyalty to her president and because she
really believed in her agenda I I 100
believe that and she just
found herself uh up against
a very selfish vice president you know I
I would say that if if anybody I I would
say that he was really if you could call
somebody evil you know I I would I would
probably point my finger at him yeah I
definitely I mean there are things that
happened that I was like okay well he's
awful now
um
have to ask you about some of your other
products coming up most specifically
asteroid City I'm so excited to see you
in it I love you in so many of these
recent projects that you've been in and
I know there's probably not much that
you can disclose I'm interested in
hearing if you can tell me anything
about it who you're playing if there was
an actor that you got to act across that
you really wanted to that that was a
that was a experience that you hadn't
had before I it was an amazing
experience
um I've been a fan of Wes Anderson for a
really really long time
um his movies have a very distinct look
he's a singular voice as a filmmaker and
that's always what I'm looking for
um I think it's so rare especially
nowadays when
um filmmakers artists are really
struggling to
um put out
something that is unique to them and is
really true to their vision and their
voice because they haven't had that
um
body of work behind them and so Wes
Anderson is really one of our um
one of the few filmmakers we have left
who can just keep doing what they want
to do you know there's there's there's
nobody who can come in there and and
give him notes on anything which I think
is so fabulous so
um
I as with all of his films they they
have an amazing an amazing ensemble cast
and so I did get to meet a lot of people
when I was working on that and it was
just kind of like oh my gosh there's
just oh boom Oh my gosh there's
fancy oh my gosh Adrian Brody like it
was just
um it was a really really fun time
um and then also
I walked into the cafeteria one day at
the place that we were staying and
Francis Ford Coppola was just having
breakfast
that's a lot like he wasn't in the movie
he was just there hanging out so
so that was that was pretty incredible I
mean that's amazing
um well I want to ask you so many other
questions but unfortunately I have to
wrap I really want to thank you for
talking with me
um this was just
uh an amazing project I really really
enjoyed your performance in it so I
really want to thank you uh for speaking
with me thank you